there are probably all of us
don't look very kindly on
made a huge thing over the hard problem
of consciousness however by
concentrating so much on consciousness
and what would what would be required
for an explanation of consciousness the
kind of thing we were talking about in
the first lecture you know and in talent
you require in talent you know or
something less I think that the area of
cognitive science is is just a happy
hunting ground for philosophy for a very
simple reason they haven't figured out
exactly what questions to ask it and
there have been a lot of interesting
false starts and and I mean just just
look at the history of psychology look I
mean look at look at look at the the
brave tries this is thus canarians and
the gestalt psychologists and the
introspection ascend the and we've had
wave after wave of enthusiasm and almost
certainly there's none of this is stupid
there's always an important contribution
to be made but it's not been anybody's
specialty within the science to sort
that out from a sort of a bird's eye
view and talk about well what in the end
does a skineri and psychology offer
after we subtract all the confusions is
it through a message era I am one who
said yes three years and people came
around to a lot of that and similarly
further sort of every every enthusiasm
we've had complex dynamical systems
right now the current hot topic and I
think for very good reasons is
predictive coding and Bayesian
approaches to modeling in the brain
these are very tempting very tempting
perspectives and so very smart people
succumb quite properly to the temptation
and throw themselves on to one bandwagon
or another and then is a merry chase now
that's very different I think from what
happens in in physics I don't think
there's anything quite I'll let the
people who in that in those areas I
think I think there's a I think there's
a there's of course this is me speaking
I find sort of leftover Cartesian
assumptions everywhere people that just
somehow can't rid themselves of the idea
that there's a place in the brain where
I am and where everything comes in and
that's where the consciousness happens
that's the Cartesian theatre as I call
it and if I put it as boldly as that
your average car the dispenser but then
but then so there's bad science I mean
you know that's there's a lot of you
know not it but there are quite a lot of
the questions that are on our board are
actually you know addressed by and
sometimes even proper you know not bad
cognizance how do you make a moral
judgment yeah what does it mean to make
a decision you know is it free and some
you know operational as sense so I know
is there conscious experience what does
it mean to recognize a word and it's me
that's the are those improper questions
no those are seem to me the questions at
the very much at the center of what
we're trying to figure out and those
ones seem to be improper
I think so I think yeah I think I think
that there's a necessitate the Nurik and
I'm excused from which I agree that this
you know a lot that's just kind of
bollocks to use here and I don't think I
needed to come to philosophy to realize
that I can take those experience are
pretty well myself not being a voice but
there's shitty experiments with you know
false assumptions that technique but
then there's also a but there's also a
less well known as a good kind of
narrowing there is that's right but do
we need does that require an interaction
between the sciences and philosophy or
experiment to come to that doesn't fall
we require but it doesn't mean does it
help either
right when we can get ideas from
whatever they come from
you